okay well let's get the latest on the
situation on the ground in ukraine for
you joining me now is the chief
executive of mackenzie intelligence
forbes mckenzie uh thanks very much
indeed for uh being with us to discuss
what really is happening in terms of on
the ground we hear a lot of rhetoric of
course but
russia
says it's hit
weapons depots in zaparizia uh in the
middle there
it says that it was storing
european and american weapons they've
said that separately western weapons are
inflaming the wall what can you tell us
about what's really going on down there
well the russian defense ministry and we
should say it's from the russian defense
ministry have stated they've been
successful in prosecuting a ballistic
missile attack on a weapons dump which
is purported to have been holding
western
um hardware
zap preacher is the area and the city
just to the north of where the
fighting's taking place now
um it's an area
that is of particular interest to the
russians the rear echelon for the
ukrainian military
um
if they have been successful
in
defeating what is western capability
that will go a long way to improving the
morale of the russian troops on the
ground bear in mind a lot of the russian
troops have been in kiev where they were
beaten
and they've now moved around
and to the area of the
the donbass
and it also will be a good news story as
well on the home front and for the
russians if it had been successful
and the british ministry of defense says
russian air activity is focused on the
south east there they couldn't dominate
the skies over the whole of ukraine
could they so
now the strategy is to take the south
east as it can can air superiority
be gained in this smaller area then sure
western analysts were surprised from the
outset that air superiority was not
gained quite quickly by russia
and the assessment has come down to the
ability for russian logistics to sustain
and the air effect
russian air integration has also not
been success it's been successful either
and that's one of the many reasons why
um they've failed to the north
but with an area round with the dumbass
about
000 square kilometers
this may be
an area that is
the russian aviation may be able to um
have an effect they may be able to
integrate the air capability with the
ground capability and it kind of ties
into the question that we've just had
um whereby we've seen a
a strike on an arms dump and really
we're seeing the kind of focus um now
shifting towards the southeast of the
country
okay let's turn our attention then to
the explosions being heard in the
breakaway region of transnistria and
moldova there are reports of russian
false flag
operations there
um what sort of military capability can
you tell us exists there then with the
russian false flag doctrine or maskarova
is is well known um the russians are
effective at doing that in the area of
transnistria which is an interesting
area to the kind of southeast and we see
it being ringed now of moldova and it's
a relic actually of from 1992 there's
about 1200 to 1500 russian troops there
a significant arms dump as well
if the stated aim of the russians is to
deny the ukraine access to the black sea
and that's the area of sea to the kind
of south of of ukraine here it would
make sense for there to be disruption on
the western flank and therefore it would
make it slightly easier but they've got
a hard slog in front of them and to move
their forces around odessa and therefore
deny access ukraine to the baltic sea
wrong the black sea sorry
looks like there's a lot going on down
there on the ground thanks very much
indeed for explaining all of that to us
forms mackenzie thank you